s'arrêter plus longuement encore sur
l'événement de la nuit aux états unis le
discours de joe biden donc devant le
congrès l'amérique va de nouveau de
l'avant nous dit nouveau président us
qui prend tout le monde de court avec
son tournant social effet d'annonce ou
vraie révolution
on va ouvrir le débat avec nos invités
juste après avoir vu ou revu les moments
forts de cette intervention c'est avec
pire auriol dorbeaux le président des
états unis joe biden a tout d'abord
remercié la vice-présidente kamala
harris et la présidente du congrès avant
de commencer son allocution devant une
assemblée entièrement masqué madame la
présidente madame la vice présidente
aucun président n'a jamais prononcé ces
mots et il était temps
après 100 jours passés à la maison
blanche
joe biden dit avoir hérité d'un pays en
crise maintenant après son jour je peux
le dire au pays l'amérique va de nouveau
de l'avant le président des etats-unis a
annoncé un programme en faveur de la
classe moyenne
le plan pour l'emploi américain va créer
des millions d'emplois bien rémunérés
des emplois sur lesquels les américains
peuvent élever une famille sur la table
un plan de dépenses massives de 1800
milliards de dollars sur dix ans dont
1000 milliards principalement dans
l'éducation et 800 milliards de
réductions d'impôts pour la classe
moyenne
pour financer ce projet le président des
états unis comptent faire payer les
entreprises et un pour cent des
américains les plus riches
je n'imposerai aucune augmentation
d'impôts personnes gagnant moins de 400
mille dollars
mais il est temps que les entreprises
américaines et que les 1 % d'américains
les plus riches commencent à payer leur
juste part
ce projet vient s'ajouter au plan climat
et infrastructures de 2000 milliards de
dollars dévoilé début avril
sur le plan diplomatique joe biden a été
ferme vis-à-vis de pékin et assure ne
pas chercher de conflit avec la chine et
qu'il est prêt à défendre les intérêts
américains dans tous les domaines est
avec nous pour le grand débat lpl ce
soir david djaïz bienvenue vous êtes
essayiste professeur à sciences po
auteur de ce lot démocratie comment
maîtriser la mondialisation et reprendre
notre destin en main nicolas tenzer et
face à vous bien
num vous êtes philosophe essayiste
président du centre d'étude et de
réflexion pour l'action politique
directeur de la revue le banquet et
spécialiste des questions stratégiques
et internationales avec nos également
mais à distance nicole bacharan
bienvenue vous êtes historienne
politologue spécialiste des états unis
vous publier bientôt je crois en
septembre les grands jours qui ont
changé l'amérique coécrit avec dominique
simonet enfin olivier babeau est avec
nous bien venu vous êtes économiste et
président fondateur de l'institut
sapiens auteurs de ce livre
le nouveau désordre numérique comment le
digital fait exploser les inégalités
merci à tous les quatre nicole bacharan
j'envie commencé avec vous parce que
vous observez vous étudiez les états
unis depuis pas mal d'années maintenant
est-ce que même vous vous avez été
surprise par les 100 premiers jours de
baden par la vigueur de sa politique
oui je peux je cours honnêtement j'ai
été assez surprise parce que c'est vrai
que d'une barre la campagne électorale
n'a ressemblé à aucune autre donc joe
biden pas la force de les sanitaires
étaient quand même très absent presque
transparent et aime beaucoup de mal à
faire campagne et puis par ailleurs le
camp républicain et donald trump en
particulier n'ont cessé de vouloir
tracer une caricature d'un homme faible
épuisé endormi et dans les capacités
cognitives seraient affaiblis et c'est
vrai que quand on voit marcher il marche
un petit à petit pas mais
intellectuellement et politiquement il
est extrêmement vigoureux il a mené ces
100 jours ses 100 premiers jours en tout
cas tambour battant
tant sur le plan sanitaire que
économiques internationales jusqu'aux
reviendront ensemble sur ces points de
vue mais en tout cas ça a été son jour
extrêmement sérieux pas du tout sexy si
vous voyez ce que je veux dire par une
crise pas de cinéma mais beaucoup de
travail et beaucoup d'avancé nicolas
tenzer vrai quand il a été élu beaucoup
ont dit
bon c'est un centriste un peu moss et
surtout kamala harris qui va tout faire
parce qu'il est trop âgé il a été
sous-estimée il était très nettement
sous-estimé parce que d'abord c'est
quelqu'un qui a une énorme expérience
quand même pas en huit ans vice
président qui a eu quand même des
positions au congrès depuis à peu près
aux 40 ans qui s'est aussi il faut le
dire entouré d'une équipe absolument
extraordinaire je pense la meilleure
équipe d'un président depuis longtemps
probablement une supérieure à celle
qu'avait obama c'est quelqu'un qui a
montré une capacité de résistance y
compris d'ailleurs sur le plan personnel
en raison des drames personnels qu'il a
vécu donc je veux dire je n'étais pas
complètement surpris de voir quelqu'un
qui avait vraiment un besoin aussi de
prouver que après ces années de
cauchemar de trump on pouvait faire
quelque chose que l'amérique était
vraiment de retour c'était un défi
personnel vraiment pour lui c'est un
défi personnel aussi pour kamala harris
pour toute son équipe est bien sûr c'est
aussi un fin tacticien politique et là
il a montré on va en parler peut-être
plus dans le détail qu'il a réussi en
fait à réconcilier les différentes ailes
du parti démocrate notamment cela le
progressiste avec elizabeth warren avec
sanders et c est une elle beaucoup plus
centriste à laquelle il appartient
naturellement donc c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui a je crois une volonté qui
a une vision claire pour l'amérique
peut-être on verra est-ce que c'est là
une sorte de nouveau new deal je vais
peut-être trop tôt pour en juger
mais c'est en tout cas quelque chose
d'extraordinaire alors le fameux slip
idiot un joe lando remis avec nicole
dataram fais allusion tout à l'heure non
pas du tout c'est au contraire aux jo
qui marche très fort et peut-être qu'en
comparaison on aura un sleeping europe à
côté ça c'est peut-être aussi une autre
crainte mais là aussi on pourra
peut-être en discuter david zayas vous
faites-le ce bilan aussi très positif
dès son premier jour vous êtes
agréablement surpris ou vous dites aussi
un peu parce que c'est c'est la petite
musique en france attention aux gaulois
rabeisen attention je suis pas tellement
surpris parce que moi ça fait trois ans
et c'est pas pour me glorifier mais que
j'annonçais la victoire de joe biden et
que je savais qu'il était capable de
renverser la table
en plus j'avais en particulier en raison
de son de son entourage à ses disruptif
je crois que c'est d'abord quelqu'un d'
extrêmement pragmatique qui a compris
quelque chose c'est que dans le contexte
actuel dans lequel se trouvent les états
unis
et avait besoin de faire campagne au
centre voire au centre-droit et de
gouverner à gauche au sens où on
investit massivement dans les
infrastructures dans l'éducation dans ce
que les américains appellent goût du
lunaret ce job ce les bons emplois se
syndicaliser parce que la classe moyenne
américaine a été laminé par à la fois le
changement technologique et la
mondialisation et qu'une partie du train
peace man fait s'est nourri de ses
fractures là et donc bye donne en fait
non seulement il applique un programme
de réparation et d'investissement dans
l'avenir mais en plus il est peut-être
en train non seulement de réconcilier
son parti mais peut-être aussi de
réconcilier son pays un pays qui est
quand même multi fracture et on a vu la
question raciale
la démocratie est quand même dans une
situation assez il n'y a pas que les
européens qui serais agréablement
surpris par ses 100 premiers jours et
que même les ennemis d'hier ceux qui ont
voté trump pourrait finalement rallié ça
en tout cas l'un des taux de progression
pour ses 100 premiers jours qui sont
très supérieurs à ce qu'ils avaient à la
fois donald trump et même barack obama
ainsi attirer leur attention
mais je crois olivier babeau je sais pas
pourquoi j'ai l'impression que vous
allez être un peu plus sceptique
dites moi non sceptique alors est ce que
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour les
européens alors cessé bien qu'on se
passionne pour la politique américaine
et il y avait que le l'épisode trump
avait de quoi passionner
ça ne manquait pas de c'était très haut
en couleurs contre tous les sens du
terme
et là on continue à ses intérêts c'est
est-ce que c'est l'intérêt de l'europe
en tout cas c'est vrai que une telle
bourde investissement un tel
investissement en infrastructure une
telle réaction fait vraiment contraste
avec avec l'europe ce qui est vrai c'est
que de toute évidence by john essaie de
s'adresser aux finalement a fait de même
des moustiques que trump c'est celui la
polarisation
aujourd'hui la société américaine de la
nécessité de la réconcilier il essaye de
le faire je pense de façon opportune en
augmentant d investissement qui avait
réellement manqué des investissements en
infrastructures des investissements
aussi en éducation qui sont une partie
de la clé est-ce que ça va suffire
je suis profondément malheureusement
persuadé que nous
parce que la fracture évidemment est le
fruit de longues décennies de délitement
et surtout ça va être intéressant de
voir les faits alors dans les sommes qui
sont annoncés il ya certaines c'est sur
10 ans 1 donc bon déjà qu'on pouvait au
maximum faire deux mandats de quatre ans
ça ça pose un peu question évidemment ça
ça grossit un petit peu le la production
par la communication mais la question
qu'on va pouvoir se poser c'est on
économise d'abord c'est risquera pas un
effet inflationniste sur à de ces
mesures parce qu'on n'a jamais vu un tel
déversement d'argent on est vraiment
dans un nouveau monde et de est-ce que
ça va vraiment réussir à faire ce
changement fondamental qui va en fait
revenir sur permettre à ces tous ces
déçus de la mondialisation de se
réconcilier avec elle sauf qu'il n'ya
pas que l'argent et les chiffres olivier
babeau il ya une vraie philosophie des
jobs des jobs des jobs c'est ce qu'il a
répété notamment cette nuit devant le
congrès il a annoncé un plan pour les
emplois américains c'est selon lui le
plan le plus ambitieux depuis la seconde
guerre mondiale il veut reconstruire les
routes les ponts les aéroports les
écoles le réseau électrique le réseau
d'eau c'est une politique de grands
travaux qu'il veut mettre en place
on va écouter si vous le voulez bien
l'un des passages forts de son
intervention la nuit dernière parce que
ça pourrait faire sursauter pas mal de
monde ici en europe écouter mes chers
compatriotes américains le ruissellement
la théorie économique du ruissellement
ça n'a jamais marché
il est temps de faire croître l'économie
à partir du bas et du milieu on est là
dans un vrai changement de paradigme à
nicole bacharan
oui oui c'est vrai que on évoque souvent
le new deal ans et que john dryden a le
portrait de franklin roosevelt dans son
bureau il le voit tout tous les matins
en face de lui ce qui est en train de se
passer
ressemble aux nuits au new deal comme
franquin
joe biden arrivé au pouvoir dans un
moment de crise extrêmement grave
aux ailes c'était la crise de 29
la plus grave qu'ait connue les 20e
siècle pardo et roosevelt a fait de
l'état fédéral au fond d'une certaine
manière le le premier employeur du pays
joe weiden n'est pas tout à fait dans
cet état d'esprit mais d'abord olivier
pas vous le disais les sommes d'argent
qu'il souhaite engager son colossal bien
plus supérieur en dollars constants à ce
qu'a pu faire
franklin roosevelt et il s'agit
d'investir dans tout ce qui manque au
fond états unis assez vous connaissez ce
pays vous savez qu'on passe rapidement
de 21e siècle et même de la science
fiction à un pays du tiers-monde dans
dans quand on roule sur les routes quand
on voit l'état des transports publics
donc investir et en même temps c'est
l'argent qui prévoit de dépenser
ça n'est pas ce ne sont pas des ailes il
a fait un plan daide 1900 milliards
c'était et non des chèques qui sont
arrivés directement dans les familles là
il s'agit d'investir et donc de créer
des emplois ce qui n'est ce qui n'est
pas là ce qui n'est pas la même chose
david jacques vous avez vu on a été très
cette partie un air de révolution point
d'interrogation vous avez une réponse à
ça moi je parle je qualifierais pas ça
de révolution comme je le disais tout à
l'heure joe biden c'est d'avoir un grand
pragmatique et c'est quelqu'un qui tient
compte de la situation des états unis
comme le disait nicole bacharan on a un
état des infrastructures très délabré
aux etats unis c'est les lignes de train
c'est les réseaux électriques c'est les
routes et les autoroutes
donc on peut faire un pas gigabit lan
d'investissement dans les
infrastructures
pareil pour ce qu'on appelle en france
l'état providence aux états unis il est
sous développée par rapport à l'europe
soit l'assurance maladie la prise en
charge du chômage et donc il ya des
marges de manoeuvre qui sont absolument
considérable sur le plan financier aussi
puisque trump avait outrancièrement
baisser les impôts sur les sociétés et
les impôt sur les grandes fortunes donc
bye 2010
je remonte le taux d'impôt sur les
sociétés à 28 % c'est-à-dire très en
deçà de ce qu'il était avant l'arrivée
au pouvoir de donald trump donc la
démarche de malheurs à la fois ya des
grands chantiers à mener et les marges
de manoeuvre financières et donc les
planètes sans un petit peu aligné pour
avoir cette ambition c'est un
pragmatique mais il théorise aussi quand
il dit mes compatriotes la théorie du
ruissellement économique n'a jamais
fonctionné c'est une théorie c'est une
conclusion je les tire après quelques
années je pense qu'il dit que justement
ça n'est pas une théorie x des sornettes
de macro économistes est que en fait lui
il fait de l'économie politique c'est à
dire qu'il regarde quel est l'état de
son pays il voit qu'il est une classe
moyenne qui a été dévastée il ya des
inégalités qui rendent la démocratie
quasiment insoutenable et lala lala
l'économie politique c'est de la
plomberie sert qu'on essaie de trouver
les mesures les plus pragmatiques les
plus efficaces pour essayer de soigner
la société est de faire en sorte que la
crise démocratique se résorbe et de ce
point de vue c'est une rupture par
rapport à l'idéologie justement
néolibérale d'un donald trump qui lui
pensait que en baissant massivement les
les impôts corporate on allait avoir une
expansion économique ce qui n'est pas du
tout le cas
et pourtant ça marchait avant la crise
due cori sa marche moyennement on fasse
dire que ça ne touchait quand même pas
je dirais la plupart des américains qui
était quand même dans un état
effectivement ça a été rappelé dans un
état pour beaucoup de pauvreté
absolument terrible aussi de son
éducation bien évidemment et je pense
que ce qui est vraiment très important
et est assez novateur aussi dans ce plan
c'est le plan pour l'éducation qui est
quelque chose d'assez unique de soutien
aux familles évidemment quellier parce
que joe boyd est lancé on peut dire
c'est sur le long terme on ne sait pas
sûr que après quatre ans à 8 ans ça
marche déjà c'est quand même l'enjeu
aussi de ce qu'on a vu avec donald trump
et avec le soutien de trucks est soudé
ducation qui a permis effectivement à ce
que toutes les théories du complot les
plus invraisemblables les choses les
plus inexacte les plus fausses de se
développer et je pense que ça c'est
quelque chose effective en est là ce
n'est pas peut-être complètement gagné
c'est de voir qu'on a toujours cette
théorie là qui donc graines en quelque
sorte les états unis et donc il va
falloir agir de ce côté là il ya
peut-être un autre chose je pense qu'il
est aussi importante c'est qu'on a un
peu l'impression parfois vu d'ici que
c'est une sorte de plan socialiste entre
guillemets 20 quand on voit quand même
le niveau à partir duquel les impôts
vont augmenter pour les amers
donc les 10 400 mille dollars en fait
concrètement pour les particuliers c'est
plutôt 5 126 mille dollars pour les
personnes seules et à peu près six cent
trente huit mille dollars pour revenus
annuels dont un peu plus de cinq cent
mille euros pour les personnes qui
vivent en couple
donc on est quand même très loin et la
suppression des niches fiscales
c'est après un million de dollars de
revenus par an donc on est quand même
très très loin de quelque chose comme
une sorte de taxation des classes
moyennes même des classes aisées
un nom que je crois qu'il faut aussi
garder aussi la proportion est donc il y
a encore beaucoup de marge de manoeuvre
mais on ne change pas radicalement avec
joe biden de système politique et de
systèmes de prélèvements économique
olivier babeau est ce que pour autant
les etats-unis pourraient devenir moins
attractif alors moins attractif pour qui
je crois que toute l'action de
belledonne repose sur une compréhension
des conditions de la prospérité au 21e
siècle les conditions la prospérité
c'est évidemment des infrastructures de
qualité
ce sont des investissements en recherche
et développement et ça fait partie du
plan il ya énormément de choses ce sont
les investissements dans la transition
écologique et il ya évidemment beaucoup
de choses et c'est encore une fois
essayé de réparer cette fracture ces
inégalités importantes alors c'est
amusant cette allusion la théorie du riz
seulement parce que personne ne l'a
jamais vue ni l'a jamais formulé ça
n'existe pas en fait la théorie du fort
dure seulement je vois j'ai fait de très
nombreuses années d'études et
l'agrégation d'économie il n'a jamais
été question de ça il faudrait qu'on me
montre le gars qui a parlé la wiz alors
oui ça n'existe pas il n'existe pas
besoin de comprendre où il s'agit on a
compris la logique il dit que ça mais ça
ne marche là en revanche il ya
effectivement l'idée qu' un pays où les
inégalités sont très forts des dictées
de revenus puis des élites est
évidemment de mode de vie puis dès le
fait de vivre à pas et est un pays qui
aura moins de chance de développer qui
aussi va donner moins de chance de façon
générale à sa population et donc c'est
ça qu'il faut empêcher etc sont ces
conditions que maiden
arrive à développer je suis pas là pour
défendre trump du tout mais faut juste
un petit peu un petit peu expliqué que
tous les malheurs d'amérique dépendent
pas de train pas le sous-investissement
il dépend des deux bien avant donc de
bama aussi je suis désolé il n'y avait
pas fait et les chèques distribués à cet
être humain l'occurrence un américain il
a reçu environ un peu plus de 3000 3500
$ ça dépend d un petit peu de ses
revenus directement sur son compte en
banque
ce n'était pas forcément des chèques six
mois c'était désire me regarderont les
doses de vaccin aussi je crois c'est
grâce à 30 plus voilà c'est il faut pas
non plus à diaboliser n'est jamais
caricaturer pardon parce que je trouve
que c'est mon cas on a envie mais c'est
effectivement assez trompeur il ya et
puis il ya quand même le côté america
first 1 qui reste extrêmement présents
chez bailleul quand il veut avoir une
augmentation des impôts pour tout le
monde pour les entreprises son mécanisme
est très clair un l'impôt ou que
l'entreprise ne paiera pas dans le monde
il sera versé au trésor américain donc
c'est toujours de l'america first nicole
bacharan est ce qu'il a un boulevard
devant lui maiden ou est ce qu'il aura
quand même des freins des freins
politiques des freins économiques ne
serait-ce que de concurrence
internationale aussi c'est non en fait
ça va être très très très difficile pour
lui
c'est vrai que là d'abord aux états unis
même la fracture politique qu'elle n'a
pas du tout disparu le plan des de baden
avec ses aides aux familles il y avait
une approbation en gros à 66%
deux pierres mais la juste avant son
discours son taux d'approbation dans le
pays étaient entre 52 et 54 %
donc on voit que le camp pro trump n'est
pas du tout convaincu pour l'instant de
la global ment en disant de la
présidence de joël et ensuite il a pu
faire passer son plan daide mais sans
plan d'infrastructure qui dépend d'abord
de réformes fiscales dont on a parlé
ensemble
il doit le faire passer devant le
congrès et pour le moment il n'y a pas
de chemin
disons pour le faire passer vous savez
qu'il enseigne notamment une maj il ya
une division à 50
50 et avec la voix prépondérante de
cavalerie ce qui peut faire 51
mais les règlements du congrès sont
extrêmement compliquées et beaucoup de
lois beaucoup d initiatives ont besoin
de 60 voix
donc il a vraiment pas un boulevard
devant lui sur le plan international on
sait tous que avec la présidence se
disent on en retrait de donald trump et
qui n'était qu'il n'a pas commencé mais
c'était de manière plus ongles sur un
royaume parce que que ce soit par
exemple quand même george bush avant lui
il y avait déjà une forme de retrait sur
la scène internationale donc on sait
aussi que au fond personne n'attend les
américains mais on ressent mais en moins
qu'ils ont encore la capacité
d'entraîner avec une partie des
démocraties dante c'est pas un boulevard
ça va être très difficile il doit
certainement faire un certain nombre de
choses mais attention à la déception qui
pourrait susciter alors oui attention la
déception surtout que depuis 1929 et ça
ne change pas pour le moment
le cycle historique de l'europe est très
largement influencée par le cycle
américain et ce qui se passe aux
etats-unis depuis cinq ou six ans je
pense que c'est très juste de dire qu'il
faut pas tout mettre sur le dos de
donald trump d'autant plus que donald
trump a participé aussi à sa façon
populiste complotistes à la prise de
conscience des méfaits d'une
mondialisation libérale consensus
libéral mal maîtrisée a eu un rôle dans
l'israël eagle dirait qu'il a eu il a
été le négatif quelque sorte qui a
permis à bayonne d'arrivée et est
souvent l'europe est le théâtre
d'événements qui ressemble beaucoup à ce
qui se passe aux etats-unis mais avec un
retard de dix ans donc il pas impossible
en fait que les secousses sismiques
qu'on observe aux états unis depuis
quelques années arrive sur le continent
européen dans des formes évidemment
spécifiques à chaque nation à sa
trajectoire politique et à son système
institutionnel mais c'est évidemment à
regarder de très près et vous faites
bien de faire le lien entre les
etats-unis et la france parce que disons
le la petite musique au sein de la
gauche française ces derniers jours
c'est un peu de gloire à baden il est en
train d'embarquer avec lui toute cette
gauche française d'hier sur ce même
plateau la porte parole du parti
socialiste gabrielle syrie houari nous
disait c'est une source d'inspiration
indéniable pour la gauche joe biden va à
l'encontre d'un certain nombre de dogmes
et d'idées reçues
de là à changer le programme des futurs
candidats à la présidentielle c'est loin
d'être certain tout simplement parce que
les états unis partent de très loin
c'est un peu ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure et c'est aussi ce que signalé ce
matin l'économiste jean pisani ferry sur
france info écoute et d'un certain
nombre de choses sur lesquelles s'est
simplement les états unis qui rattrape
qui font un pas ou quelques pas de la
direction du modèle européen
quand il nous dit que on va développer
les congés payés qu'eux on va s'assurer
de ce que l'éducation à partir de l'âge
de trois ans est accessible pour les
familles américaines
quand il dit que l'on doit pouvoir aller
à l'université
faire ses premières années de collège
pas d'ailleurs dans n'importe quelle
université ne donnait pas les community
college sans payer bon c'est très en
retard par rapport au modèle européen
donc nous ne croyons pas quand même que
tout ce que fait ben hayden mais
simplement un exemple à suivre
donc attention à ne pas inverser les
choses c'est lui qui s'inspire dans
notre modèle oui absolument non je pense
que je jean pisani ferry a tout à fait
raison effectivement sur ce plan là
c'est à dire que si on regarde le niveau
de protection sociale que nous avons en
france notamment et dans beaucoup de
pays européens certes pas tous mais
quand même en france notamment
c'était un niveau de protection sociale
nettement supérieur non seulement à
celui qui existe aux états unis mais
même à celui qui résultera de
l'application du plan by donne s'il est
intégralement appliquées je veux dire ça
il faut il faut pas non plus oublier
effectivement ce phénomène là donc
et puis ensuite deuxièmement byden
n'envisage pas de changer le système il
faut voir aussi qu'on est dans un
système aussi fédéral qui est très
différent donc là il reprend un peu en
quelque sorte me redonne une sorte de
poids à l'état fédéral par rapport aux
états fédérés mais avec des limites
également intrinsèque à ce système où il
ne peut pas tout faire il ya des
compétences évidemment des états fédérés
qui l'ont nettement supérieur ce n'est
pas aux régions aux départements chez
nous il ya également des choses que baye
donne aura beaucoup de difficultés à
faire sur laquelle il est pourtant très
engagée par exemple la suppression de la
vente libre dans certains états des
armes à feu qui est effectivement qu'il
a dit c'était pandémie véritablement et
il a évidemment totalement raison mais
là il ira effectivement il pourra pas
aller jusqu'au bout donc je pense que ça
peut être une inspiration sur le
mouvement
mais encore une fois on est dans un
système tout à fait différent ce qui est
aussi quand même prodigieux c'est que
byden veut aussi restaurer quelque chose
qui n'est jamais complètement disparu
parce que éthiques
il est un peu affaibli mais quand même
pas considérablement qui est tout le
système de recherche pour quand on voit
aussi ce qu'il a dit sur le plan cancer
sur le développement de la recherche
pour voir qu'on a beaucoup parlé du
defla amérique n ya jamais eu
véritablement de déclin américain et la
bei den rajoute une couche en disant
mais on va vraiment rester la puissance
dominante en matière de dynamisme
économique de recherche d'innovation et
ça c'est quelque chose peut-être
effectivement inspirant pour l'europe
mais que les pays européens tous seuls
chacun des pays européens ne peut pas
faire on n'a pas la capacité
effectivement y compris on l'a vu sur le
plan logistique avec avec le vaccin mais
américain on n'a pas la capacité
logistique de lover on n'a pas les
conditions aussi pour créer ou en europe
l'équivalent d'un steve jobs ou de dinde
un grand innovateur de ce type là parce
que tout simplement il n'y a pas les
capacités de développement et je pense
le sas effectivement ce qui est
intéressant c'est pas de dire on va
copier le modèle américain parce qu'on
ne le peut pas mais ceux de voir quelles
sont les sources d'inspiration et les
grandes trajectoire ils doivent nous
inspirer sur le plan européen
et là on en est loin on prend l'eau
potable peut-être de partie d'une
politique internationale
on est très loin aussi sur le plan
international d'avoir la capacité de
changer quand même un certain nombre de
comportements on l'a vu avec la turquie
récemment avec le soutien de la turquie
a apporté à l'ukraine par exemple on n'a
pas la capacité d'agir comme les états
unis peuvent encore le faire parce qu'en
attendant il fait des émules olivier
babeau vous l'avez senti vous aussi dans
cette seconde française envoyée hier la
sénatrice écologiste esther benbassa a
twitté on veut la même chose chez nous
oui bah c'est quand même le premier a
entériné cette entrée dans ce nouveau
monde assez extraordinaire pour la
politique ou la contrainte budgétaire a
disparu parce que c'est ça jusqu'à
maintenant bon il était quand même
question un peu taux d'endettement il
était question de la dette
quand vous regardez les chiffres entre
ce qui est proposé et ce qui est mis en
face en disant on va augmenter les
impôts sur les plus riches
en effet c'est vraiment les plus riches
quand vous regardez c'est vraiment les
impôts vraiment marginaux les plus hauts
et même si vous augmentez un peu la peau
sur les sociétés et même avec l'idée
d'essayer de récupérer un peu d'argent
sur la fraude fiscale sur l'optimisation
parce que il augmente aussi les moyens
de contrôle on doute vraiment beaucoup
la capacité des du seconde financer le
premier donc ça va se financer par
création monétaire par endettement et je
crois que c'est surtout ça en fait
aujourd'hui qui fait que bayonne est
précurseur probablement d'un mouvement
dont je gagerais bien qu'il aura des
traductions politiques en europe et pas
forcément en france
peut-être si ailleurs c'est à dire
l'idée qu' on peut ouvrir grandes les
vannes de effectivement de
l'investissement puisque on l'a
tellement fait en fait depuis maintenant
un peu plus d'un an pour aider les
copies qu'on s'est rendu compte que pour
l'instant jusqu'ici tout va bien
quelque sorte on a créé énormément
d'argent à partir de rien et on l'a
distribué ça a été même quelque part
même des formes d'hélicoptères monnaie
on l'a dit aux états unis donnent de
l'argent directement aux ménages on perd
on passe pas par les mécanismes
financiers et on s'aperçoit que ça a des
effets donc je pense qu'en effet va y
avoir une demande de plus en plus forte
dans beaucoup de pays européens pour pas
une augmentation justement de ces
investissements nous j'ai envie de dire
pour conclure qu'on avait un petit peu
commencé quand même c'est à dire que ça
fait longtemps en nous qu'on est en
déficit important est que on a un déport
déficit d'investissement en tout cas en
france dans certains domaines on peut
pas dire que ce n'était pas des choses à
faire sur l'enseignement supérieur et la
recherche pensionnat weeds
oui moi j'ai entendu jean pisani-ferry
dire effectivement les états unis imite
le modèle européen je pense qu'il faut
rester assez humble sur ces questions
c'est à dire qu'effectivement on est on
est beaucoup plus avancée en matière
d'état social et dont il ya des marges
de manoeuvre sur ce terrain là en
revanche s'il ya des des sujets de
préoccupation en europe aujourd'hui je
pense à son décrochage technologique
je pense aussi au fait qu'elle se veut
en position de leadership sur la
transition écologique sauf que tout ce
que l'europe arrive à faire pour le
moment c'est l'énorme des taxes et des
réglementations or ce que nous montre
les états unis ce que nous montre aussi
la chine
rappelez vous chie jean ping qui a
annoncé à l'automne la volonté
d'atteindre la neutralité carbone en
2060 c'est que la transition écologique
ça va nécessiter des investissements
massifs un effort technologique des
changements de comportement il ya un
plan d'électrification aux états unis
qui est absolument spectaculaire il ya
un plan dans les semi conducteurs
il ya des dizaines de milliards qui sont
déversées sur la recherche développement
l'europe pour le moment elle est
complètement à la rue par rapport à ce
niveau d'engagement ça ne met dix
longueurs d'avancé pas dix longueurs
d'avancé mais je pense que si ça
continue comme ça et effectivement on a
une europe qui en décrochage par rapport
aux états unis et à la chine
donc il faut rester un peu humble quand
on dit que les états unis ne font que
rattraper le modèle en amérique si je
puis me permettre un point effectivement
je suis entièrement d'accord avec
effectivement ce que ce que david a
évoqué mais je réponds aussi juste un
point sur ce que disait olivier babeau
moi je suis entièrement d'accord avec
lui mais sauf que les états unis peuvent
se permettre effectivement sans doute
d'avoir cet endettement est d'avoir
cette politique budgétaire actes
très active que nous en europe nous
sommes probablement pas capable d'avoir
c'est l'une des différences aussi
fondamentale nicole bacharan fusée oui
c'est vrai que le disons c'est démarrage
spectaculaire de joe biden ça secoue un
peu les différents partis politiques
européens et singulièrement français
alors c'est vrai que dire byden
s'inspire du modèle européen je pense
que quand on parle de modèle social de
protection sociale de crèches
l'éducation gratuite il ya quelque chose
de cela mais mais par contre ce n'est
pas du tout la gauche française telle
qu'elle est telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui parce que joe biden incarne
il ne consommait week-end qu'on pourrait
qualifier de social-démocrate
essentiellement axé sur les questions
économiques et sociales éducation
également se tenant aussi loin que
possible et ça il y en a besoin pour
essayer de garder son parti uni d'aussi
loin que possible des questions
identitaires
on a évoqué ensemble les chiffres d'un
taux les d'augmentation d'impôts pour
les ménages gagnant plus de 400 mille
dollars par an c'est pas du tout la
france est soumise c'est pas du tout les
déclarations qu'on a pu avoir à gauche
par moments sur voilà les riches c'est
3000 euros si vous gagnez 3000 dollars
par mois aux états unis pour sauver un
crédit d'impôt à la fin de l'année payez
pas d'impôts donc ce n'est pas du tout
l'extrême gauche y lisons que certains
en france peut-être fantasmes il me
semble qu'ils occupent davantage une
place d'une gauche pragmatique modérée
sociale démocrate qui est étrangement
pauvres est amenuisée en france il nous
reste 30 secondes s'ils voulaient
conclure
olivier la gauche que vous vouliez dire
quelque chose rapidement week en effet
permettre beaucoup de choses quand vous
avez le dollar et que c'est une monnaie
tellement demandé qu' on a l'impression
vous pouvez en créer
ad libidum est en effet c'est
probablement pas le cas des pays qui ont
l'euro donc on n'a pas exactement les
évidemment les mêmes les mêmes contrats
et ce sera le mot de la fin de ce débat
passionnant merci à tous d'y avoir
participé je crois qu'on a fait tomber
quelques idées reçues et quelques
clichés sur tout ce qu'on entend au tour
de joe biden
ces derniers jours merci beaucoup dit
avoir participé c'est donc la fin de
cette émission on se retrouve lundi à 18
heures et à 22 heures demain bonjour
chez vous cette heure et demie édition
spéciale autour de l'interview du
président de la république dans la
presse quotidienne régionale et autour
de ce calendrier qu'il a précisé ce
calendrier de déconfinement organes
mancini recevra notamment guillaume
larrivé députés aient l'air de l'yonne
je vous souhaite une excellente soirée
sur public sénat